-Our next guest
is an award-winning,
best-selling author.
His fantastic new book,
"A Swim in a Pond in the Rain,
in which four Russians
give a master class on writing
reading, and life, is out now.
Please welcome back to the sho
one of my all-time favorites
George Saunders.
Hello, George.
-Hey, Seth.
How are you doing?
-I am doing wonderful.
This is a fascinating book
because it's a collection
of short stories from Russia
authors that are combined
basically with you
teaching a class on these works,
which is something
that you've done
for years
at Syracuse University.
What made you think that thi
would be the sort of book
that people would
want to get into?
-Yeah, it's not a natural
selling pitch, you know?
A highly technical book
with tables and figures
about some dead people.
Really, you know, I had --
Our students at Syracuse,
we get about 700 application
a year,
and we let 6 people come.
So they're just off the charts
great writers.
And over the years, this class
that I teach about the Russian
has been my favorite.
And I think it's been, you know,
one that they like, too.
So it's really just kind of like
going back to the basics o
what is a story, you know,
how does it work?
How do we get pulled into one?
How do we get kicked out?
And the point is that
by reading these stories
and studying them closely,
they'll figure out how to,
you know, write the stuff
that only they could write
So it's kind of like
story morgue.
You know, we take these things
and we just slow it down
and try to see why they work
-I always say to
college students
when they ask me for advice --
one thing I always try to
impart on them is college is
sort of the last time
people give you time to read
And what this book helped me
realize as well
is you never read again
in your life
with someone sort of
going along with you,
helping you understand
the context of this,
which is what this book
does so beautifully.
And another thing is you also --
the first time
you read these stories,
you didn't quite understan
the depth of them as well.
You tell
a really interesting story
which one of your professors
the wonderful short-story writer
Tobias Wolff,
read this out loud,
and you sort of didn't kno
until you heard it out lou
how funny Chekhov was.
-No, that's right, and I kind of
knew I wanted to be a writer
but I wasn't positive, and Tob
gave a reading in Syracuse
where, instead of
reading his own work,
he read these three storie
by Chekhov.
And the room was just on fire.
It was so funny and so,
you know, it'd be funny,
and the next minute,
you're almost crying.
And that's when
I kind of decided
I want to be a storywriter
And also, you know,
with this book, these Russians
we kind of think they're
philosophical, which they are.
And a lot of people think
they're hard or inaccessible
But that reading by Toby
showed me
that they're really just stories
from the heart.
You know, they're about things
that we actually face in life.
And they're real frank
and they're real funny.
So that's why I teach them
because they're sort of
essences of story.
-It's interesting because,
of course, you read these book
from a modern perspective,
and you don't have a ton
in common with the sort of lif
these characters you're reading.
But you do have a deep empathy
for them.
And is that one of the thing
you try to really press on
your young writers,
is how important it is
to feel what these character
are feeling?
-Yeah, I think that's
the whole beauty of the story.
You know, like, in real life
you're walking down the street
and some guy walks by.
And you quickly glance at hi
and you make some projection
and you like him or don't like
him, you dismiss him.
But in the world of the story,
you know,
guided by somebody like Chekhov,
you turn around and you get to
go into that guy's head,
and you stay there for 15 pages.
And if you're reading
a great story,
you basically become
that person,
even if you, in real life,
you wouldn't have liked hi
or you would have been
bored by him.
So there's something
really lovely about that.
You know, to be reminded, one,
that other people are
just as real as you are.
And, two, that if you
could actually occupy
somebody's reality
for a few minutes,
you'd actually feel more tende
towards them.
I think that's the great lesso
of literature,
is life goes by so fast.
But a story is almost like
in "The Matrix"
when time slows down.
And you get to inhabit
somebody else and go,
"Oh, this is how her mind works.
This is how this person
suddenly became angry."
And it's not something
you get to do in real life
But in stories,
it's like a scale model
of the way that people live.
And I think, in the end,
at least when I'm reading it
it makes me a little more tender
towards people
and then also
a little more alert
to the beauty of the world
just for, maybe, you know,
15 minutes afterwards
or something.
-Can you talk about
how stories enter --
I believe you said they sort o
enter our mind as a memory
-Yeah, I think neuroscientists
are saying that
when you read a good story
it's coming in basically
by the same route
as an actual memory.
And I think it's stored in
a similar way, too.
So this means that basically
if you have an energetic
reading life of good stories
you're getting all these
ancillary lives, basically
lives that you don't have time
to live.
And you're also
kind of being reminded
that things have been
other ways, you know?
Things are other ways right no
than the story
that we're telling in our minds.
So I think it's kind of like
consciousness expanding,
you know?
It gives you a chance to see -
Well, what it actually does is
it works against the delusio
that you're the most important
thing in the world, you know
The idea that
we all inherit from birth,
which is that
it's the "Seth Meyers" show.
Really, it is, you know,
that everybody out there
is just for your --
you know, for your amusement
We kind of intellectually
know that's not true,
but basically we live
as if it is true.
So when you read a good story,
you're kind of being lured out
of yourself.
And you're having
someone else's experience.
And if nothing else,
you snap back to yourself
and go, "Oh, my God.
Everybody else is as real
as I am,
and they're also having
these powerful thoughts
of their own identity."
-I think sometimes people woul
think this is more important
in things like screenwriting
or writing for television.
But you make it clear that even,
you know, Tolstoy or Chekhov had
that pressure of convincin
people to stay with them
as readers from each sentenc
to the next.
-Yes.
I got a great lesson one tim
from Bill Buford,
who was the fiction editor o
"The New Yorker" at that time.
And I had given him this story
called "Sea Oak"
that I really liked
and I had worked on it
for five or six years,
so I thought it was perfect.
And he was cutting it up, and we
were moving things around.
And, you know,
I got really insecure.
And, of course, at that moment
you go fishing for a compliment.
So I'm like, "You know, Bill
what do you like
about the story?"
And he just took
a real long beat, you know
And he said,
"Well, I read a sentence,
and I like it enough
to go on to the next one."
And that was it.
So it's kind of
an amazing thing.
Like, when you really
get down to it,
whether you're telling stories
through screenplays
or short stories or novels
that really is the whole game.
If a person gets to sentence
four and is offended enoug
to check out of the story,
then you're done.
So you're really just trying t
keep the person
moving through the sentences
And what I found is all th
things that we learn in school
you know, things that kind o
are buzzkills like theme
and character and three-ac
structure and all that,
that stuff is
all contained in that.
If you can keep a person
reading for 20 pages,
I guarantee there will be
character development
and there will be plot
and there will be theme.
So it's kind of
an amazingly simple
and yet infinitely complex way
to approach a story
when you're reading.
With my students, like, "Okay,
when did you buy into the story?
When did it offend you?
When did you decide
you hated the story?"
If you can bear down on that
you learn so much about storie
but also about your own mind
you know?
What is it that will make yo
suddenly disappear into a stor
and it's actually happenin
in front of you?
On the other hand,
what makes you throw a boo
across the room
because it's so false, you know?
But I think all of storytellin
is just in that little impulse
of "Am I going to
keep going or not?"
I talked to somebody who i
a podcaster the other day,
and she said, "Well, you know,
for us, it's kind of simple.
We just don't want people
to hit stop," you know?
-It's the age-old problem
for people
who are trying to hold
anyone's attention.
I really -- I mean, I love
reading these stories.
Obviously, you selected ones
that meant a lot,
and you were not wrong there
But it was so wonderful
to read it,
knowing that I was going o
the journey with you.
Thanks for writing it
and thanks for being here.
It's always a pleasure
to see you, George.
-Oh, thank you for having me on,
Seth. Good to see you again.
-"A Swim in a Pond in the Rain
is out now.